Sí aquí en quibe ya es de noche y sin
embargo hace algunas horas hemos vuelto
a oír las sirenas antiaeras y también
por supuesto los estallidos que siguen a
las a las sirenas antiaéreas en algunas
ocasiones esto significa que los
enfrentamientos entre el ejército
ucraniano y las tropas rusas continúan
continúan en distintas partes de la
ciudad y según Fuentes militares
occidentales Fuentes que hemos
consultado esto también indicaría que la
resistencia del ejército ucraniano está
haciendo más fuerte de lo esperado
además de eso ahí también
enfrentamientos en otras ciudades de
Ucrania por ejemplo unos de los últimos
ha sido en la ciudad de María porque se
encuentra en el sureste del país y a
esto se está reflejando por supuesto
también en la población civil que sigue
inten
alejarse de las zonas de conflicto y
alcanzar las regiones del oeste y en
algún caso también cruzar la frontera
con Polonia o con Rumanía para poner su
vida a salvo esto podría haberse
interrumpido en el día de mañana dado
que hay informaciones de que habría
dificultades para salir de la ciudad en
dirección precisamente de estas regiones